daylight savings time saving time I
should say in spring we change our
clocks do we change the time so it's
earlier or later in spring in spring now
here is exactly why I'm talking about
this right now instead of talking about
time first I'm going to give you an
anchor which I hope I find helpful I
hope you find helpful as well and spring
you're coming out of winter right so is
the Sun coming up earlier or is it
coming up later
sunrise is earlier so think about this
right yeah chef you have a question
Oracle so they say spring forward fall
back which is an American way of saying
it because for but I still find and this
is autos where this because people still
find that confusing if sunrises earlier
think about what this means okay
are you looking at the window and it's
like 6:00 a.m. it's 6:00 a.m. and you're
like I don't want to get up at 6:00 a.m.
but the Sun is already getting up and
it's getting up earlier and earlier and
earlier does that make sense
so here's what we do we change 6:00 a.m.
into 7:00 a.m. okay because we're like
look it's bright it's right get up do
something right it's not some weird
ungodly hour it's plenty bright out
there there's plenty of light it's a
time when everyone should be out and
about okay so we change the clocks we
move them forward okay so we spring
forward and during summer the sunrise
keeps on getting earlier and earlier and
that way you don't get up and think oh
my goodness it should bright outside but
it's still quite and early times would
bring it forward okay
when do we change it for us we would say
in autumn but if you want to use what
other parts of the world
for finally why is it called for the
leaves all fall down in autumn sunrises
later so we were in daylight eating time
all the way through spring and summer
but then the Sun starts to get up later
and later and later and you're like it's
7 a.m. 8 a.m. and it's still dark out
there what's going on so what we do is
we bring the clocks back to what they
were before so we would change say 7
a.m. well my goodness it's dark out
there no one want to get up at this time
so we say we change that into 6 a.m. we
change the clocks back yeah so why do we
do this why do we do this it's because
we're trying to take advantage of these
things right put it this way right when
the Sun is up people can do stuff a lot
more easily than I mean I know we have
electric light and all that kind of
thing
but you can function you don't need
there are certain things that can't be
done until the Sun is up like say what a
construction work you can't just it's
expensive to put life everywhere ok so
the time that the Sun comes up is an
important time to say okay now that
there is light we can start doing stuff
we should start doing stuff okay
otherwise you're basically sleeping and
wasting as opposed to saving you're
wasting all this time when there's
daylight you should use that time so
therefore we change the clocks in this
way okay now along with forward and back
I want to talk about sleep right because
we talked about losing sleep and gaining
sleep which one is which if we move the
clocks forward right so now 6 a.m. is 7
a.m. now right mmm it's ok if 6 a.m. has
been changed into 7 a.m. and school
starts at 8:30 right so you walk in but
everyone's clocks don't say 8:30 anymore
what's happened to the clocks they say
9:30 so you're like wait I'm late I
missed almost all of period 1 so what
are you going
to do to actually be on time you're
going to have to wake up earlier does
this make sense so you have lost an hour
of sleep because you've got to wake up
earlier to be in keeping with the
sunrise in daylight saving time haha
that's funny so now therefore as an
opposite right in um in autumn as things
get colder you gain sleep right okay
that's right
so circadian rhythm all I'm going to be
okay does this make sense just okay so
thankfully Australia we're pretty simple
in that we only do one our other places
around the world some places do weird
half-hour things but we try to keep it
relatively simple